e
la voiture à 7 heures tous les matins
tous les jours et toute la semaine
c'est un endroit vraiment bien
petton loyers les trois quarts de ton
salaire
v le peu qui reste
dans l'essence de découvert
ce qu'elle prenne pour ces petites
pas savoir ce que c'est
première fois que je les ai vus devant
son immeuble
je pouvais pas croire qu'elle était vrai
maintenant quand elle me parle des fois
il s'est
tu peux faire est plutôt de taper sur la
gueule
ce nouveau la place il ya deux ans
le service militaire
j'ai rencontré j'ai mangé avec sa mère
une appli crédit deux semaines après
quand j'arrive à 8 heures avec les
collègues
monsieur pinto monsieur c'est paulo
on se change dans les vestiaires
puis rapporté au bureau
je sais paulo il a fait 8 ans l'angola
ça a laissé comme un trou dans son
cerveau
ni quand il est revenu après ça
plus supporté d'entendre content ce soir
j'ai pinto lit ça fait 30 ans qu'il est
un pays sa famille était propriétaire
milliers son frère ils s'entendaient pas
alain bagnoud son père aimant à la ferme
sa mère lui à des parties
c'est un paquet ses affaires
devenu dans sa chambre
au lieu de la moitié de son porte
monnaie
monsieur pinto quand j'imagine à 20 ans
il a toujours sa tête de maintenant
sofame est mort l'année dernière
ça faisait trois ans seulement qui se
connaissent
quand on a fait l'école comme moi
à faire autre chose
bré pas fait autre chose que ça
e
on chante le soir je m'arrête un peu
plus haut
je téléphone je coupe la radio
vers les autres gens
je
j'en portais toujours un peu de son
odeur avec moi
nancy sera prêt pas s'ils
disparaissaient
la différence
samedi
l'idf quelque chose de mieux comme
cette fille-là avec le garage
ac les rues les maisons toujours pareil
sûrement quelque chose de mieux c'est
vrai
je ne sais pas ce que c'est
je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas comment on fait
et